hey youtubers is Charlie so yesterday
during my episode for review I asked you
to submit all your big questions about
the WTF reveal at the end and all the
big changes they made to the book so I
picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question also real
quick high fives - Noah Lieberman you
are this week's giveaway winner I'll be
DMing you and your channel for details
but you basically win a $20 Amazon gift
card so the next round round 5 will
start whenever I post my episode 5
review Nick's Sunday if you're finding
me for the first time I also do you know
queue days like this just to follow up
on really big things that happen and the
big videos that do like Game of Thrones
arrow Doctor Who so be sure to subscribe
to get everything and feel free to leave
me suggestions for future bonus videos
to do so let's answer some questions
careful for spoilers from episode 4 if
you haven't seen it yet but here we go
number 1
Blake Targaryen asks where the Dragons
kept whenever we're not seeing them next
to Daenerys so they basically hunt for
themselves at this point so instead of
riding around in those crates like they
did whenever they were little they fly
free all the time
so if they're not right there with her
just assume they're out killing large
animals they will be back soon though
there are a few shots and the trailers
that we haven't seen yet they just save
money for other big CG shots by not
using them in every episode I actually
really like the designs of this season
George are Martin even posted some
artwork for a full-size balerion that's
going to be in the new world of Ice and
Fire book this winter just look at that
scale - look at how big the dragon is in
relation to Aegon that's prob about how
big drogon is gonna get question number
two Chris Todd asks if Locke takes the
Nights Watch both and ends up completing
his mission to kill Brandon Jon Snow and
then returns to Bolton wouldn't he be
branded a deserter and sentenced to
death so yes that's totally assuming
though that Roose Bolton upholds the law
and kills you know deserters of the
Nights Watch but it doesn't really look
like he cares too much about justice so
if Locke were to be successful in his
mission and head back to Bolton the only
way he'd faced the chopping block like
that brother Ned Stark beheaded in
season 1 is if one of the more honorable
houses caught him and right now
I'm gonna go ahead and say that there
aren't a whole lot of those in power and
really the only way you'd know someone
was a brother of the Nights Watch is
that they were wearing the black or if
they told you so
all Locke has to do is just change his
clothes but to be clear I don't think
Locke is gonna be successful I think
he's gonna end up getting killed you
know hopefully by a white Walker
like you know cold hands are just a
regular white Walker or by brand who is
warmed into someone else question number
three Raquel Braga asks what's the
difference between the White Walkers and
the blue-eyed people that come back from
the dead so the White Walkers are
actually living beings they're turned
from living beings and the undead are
actually called whites they're
reanimated corpses the white walkers
practice necromancy so if they find dead
bodies or they kill people they turn
them into zombies that obey their
commands those are called whites even
though we did see that baby get turned
into a white Walker we haven't really
seen a white Walker reanimate a bunch of
corpses like see it actually happened
question number four seraya asks are you
happy with all the changes and how
they're changing characters arcs so yeah
it is a little bit strange but I totally
don't mind they are still really good
storytellers and the interesting thing
we should really be talking about is how
these changes are going to affect what's
going to happen later in the story
george RR martin actually use the term
butterfly effect
you know wherein you change something
early on it has you know massive ripple
effects much much later in the story so
you know like someone dies or doesn't
die that's supposed to die in season one
and it dramatically affects what you
have to do with the story in like season
three or four it feels like he's kind of
setting us up for a time when the show
will become unrecognizable from the
books but they do still operate based on
the original character art so even
though the order of events might change
or where characters physically travel
like bran being at Craster's now their
character development will still be the
same like all the major mega events
still happen like the purple wedding but
the way the characters get there is just
chained just a little bit they've also
been adding things the george RR martin
didn't originally tell in the books like
in the case of that moment with the
white walkers that's something that was
probably going on during book 2 and 3
but martin just never wrote it in so
chronologically they didn't spoil wins a
win or anything they just chose to show
us a part of Westeros that Martin didn't
focus on so they could always end up
doing that for other characters and
other places in the story so be prepared
for other you know additional scenes
like this one question number five
trafalgar law asks do you think that one
of the white walkers seen in this
episode was cold hands so the white
Walker that we saw here is actually the
night's king in the mythology of the
book
he was the 13th Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch
that was like 8,000 years ago almost you
know close to the time whenever the wall
was first built after the last great
battle with the White Walkers the story
goes on that he was out on patrol north
of the wall and met a woman that looked
kind of like the Bride of Frankenstein
and fell in love with her whenever he
had sex with her supposedly he lost his
soul and started looking like we saw him
on the show it implies that by giving
himself to her he lost his soul and she
turned him into a white Walker that
woman was called the Knights Queen and
the two of them went on to enslave a big
portion of the Nights Watch and
eventually they were defeated after this
big great battle and everyone just kind
of forgot about him for a long time but
since that person we just saw was him it
looks like he just retreated and created
a new center for power for the great
other it looks like he's just been
slowly replenishing their ranks over the
years from sacrifices by people like
Craster if you look in the background of
one of the shots whenever he's revealed
it actually gives some visual clues as
to his identity - it seems like the
writers put those 12 other white walkers
behind him to represent the 12 other
Lord commanders that came before him
obviously he only became Lord Commander
after they died so the people behind him
aren't the actual people it's just a
visual easter egg question number six
effective kill asks if white walkers are
made from babies where did the first
white walkers come from so we don't
really know anything about the long
night you know the last great war with
great other after that ended Brandon
Stark built the wall you know that's why
he's called bran the Builder like I said
that was about 8,000 years ago but it
seems like the night's king became the
first new white Walker after that if he
really is a white Walker and not just
something different
it's also possible that the Nights Queen
was the first new white Walker and she
turned him because you know he was human
until she took a soul we don't know a
lot about her yet either hopefully the
new books will actually fill those gaps
as for all the new White Walkers that we
are seeing on the show now it looks like
it's just taken them so long to
replenish their ranks because they're
raising them up from babies so they have
to do it one at a time it seems like
anyone who worships the great other
sacrifices their male sons but not
everyone in the North actually worships
him the wildlings actually mostly
worship the gods of the forest right now
though we don't know how many White
Walkers actually exist but the baby we
saw was supposedly Craster's 99th son
so there's at least a hundred White
Walkers if you include the night's king
they do all possess a certain level of
magic so it would be like you know a
hundred mello Sandra's although some of
them are probably just warriors question
number seven lizzy asks what was the
point of carl drinking wine from joe or
more mutt skull i think they were just
trying to make bern Gorman's character
seems just as evil as the White Walkers
and say like you know Ramsay snow like
just as evil as all the other really
evil characters on the show remember
Daenerys speech about answering
injustice with justice Carl is like the
injustice part of that I think they let
him go like a little crazy over the top
just because they liked his performance
so much burn gorman was totally great
and there was this really Shakespearean
flare he had when he was talking to that
skull I feel like that's a scene that
all the theater geeks would really enjoy
you know you could actually perform that
is like a one-person scene at school in
fact if anyone actually wants to give
that a try and recreate that either like
at home or at school I'll totally give
you a shout out just send me like a
youtube link question number eight
bilious asks do you think the Tommen
will stay good or will he also become as
evil as Joffrey so I think it's implied
that he has a good heart if he does end
up surviving to adulthood he probably
won't develop the same madness that
Joffrey in King Aerys developed remember
seriously said that whenever Joffrey was
little he was totally normal he only
started to go mad as he got older and
Barristan Selmy actually said the same
thing about King Aerys you know Daenerys
his father he was normal too until he
you know slowly turned into the Mad King
I actually always kind of thought that
george RR martin was subtly trying to
imply that you know because of all the
inbreeding and sister wives that the
Targaryen and Cersei and Jaime did you
know this madness that they all
developed was some form of punishment in
reality it's probably just some genetic
anomaly that has to do with the
inbreeding you know in fact I was
actually always amazed that the
Targaryen didn't have more birth defects
or you know quote-unquote
crazy kings supposedly though you know
sister wiping back in Valyria was a
normal thing to do just because the
ability to ride dragons was passed along
genetically and in order to keep that
genetic link as strong as possible they
just try to keep their bloodlines were
like pure question number nine Nik naks
asks how are the story changes going to
influence brand story so I think he's
still gonna travel to meet the
three-eyed raven eventually I think he's
just gonna be a little bit delayed you
know he's on a bit of a sidetrack
the finale you know episode 10 is
supposedly titled the children so I
think the children of the forest will
get involved somehow and end up helping
him they also have the green site like
bran so anytime they pop up it will
probably be as part of his storyline no
confirmation on whatever they're gonna
pop up if it's gonna be before the
finale
question number 10 the vst's what's the
difference between the great other the
person we saw at the end and the White
Walkers so the great other is the
diametric opposite of the red god that's
the person that Melisandre worships
they're like a yin and yang supernatural
force and they always exist in
relationship to the other you always
define one in terms of the other so when
one is in power the other is not like
the way people mythologize the Sun and
the moon I suppose the show is making it
seem like the red God you know or the
god of light is Mel Sandra says is good
and the great others evil but I always
kind of think of them as more of like
neutral forces of chaos like the red God
isn't like a warm fuzzy God so really
the great other is just this unseen
supernatural force the person we saw was
the night's king think of him as like
the leader of the White Walkers and the
other White Walkers are just normal
soldiers like I said they all possess
certain levels of magic the one we saw
here the night's king is just more
powerful than the others and one last
bonus question Arman asks when are we
going to learn more about the lands of
always winter so we're not actually
gonna travel to that place at least in
the books until winds of winter the ice
fortress that we saw at the end of this
episode is at some indeterminate
location in the north it could be
anywhere they didn't really specifically
say where so thank you so much for so
many questions these videos are always a
ton of fun to do especially when really
crazy you know happens in the
episodes like this big White Walkers
scene and because of that my next bonus
video is probably gonna be on the long
night and the building of the wall that
was like the last great war with the
White Walkers like 8,000 years ago so I
think it'd be really fun to talk about
that be sure to subscribe to get that
and feel free to leave me suggestions
for all kinds of future bonus videos
there's all kinds of stuff we can talk
about so right now click here to get my
review the episode and click here to
learn all about the Bloodraven thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
you